en plena ola contra ayuso
la nueva guerra del pp contra el gobierno se centra
en la falta de médicos
la ministra de sanidad con el pp
ha acusado al gobierno
de estar detrás de la falta de médicos
por no convocar suficientes plazas mir
le exigimos que no se desentienda
y que afronte de una vez por todas esta situación
y diferentes dirigentes del partido
insisten en este argumento
para desviar las críticas a ayuso
no crean plazas de médicos
no amplían la oferta de los mir y la culpa la tiene
los presidentes del pp
creemos que en españa hace falta médicos
y hace falta plazas mir
el gobierno de españa
mantenga bloqueado el incremento de las plazas mir
y y qué dicen los datos
pues que sí faltan médicos
pero las plazas de médicos residentes
han subido de forma importante
con el actual gobierno
el gobierno de sánchez ha convocado 8500 plazas mir
frente a 5h
1600 de la última convocatoria de ana pastor
como ministra de sanidad
un 50% más de hecho
las plazas bajan cuando el pp llega al gobierno
y suben cuando lo hace la izquierda